bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 8 juin
bienvenue sur tv fil 78 nouvelle semaine
d'actualité locale voici les principaux
titres qui seront développés au cours de
la prochaine demi heure la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
victimes de réductions budgétaires
programmées par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines les opposants à
cette décision se sont mobilisés anish
kapoor exposé au château de versailles
l'artiste plasticien contemporain
entendez bouleversé l'ordre avec ses
créations mission accomplie au delà des
espérances avec une nouvelle polémique
sur la place de l'art contemporain dans
la cité royale
et puis et d'une reine à l'autre la
reine des neiges en tout cas
l'interprète de la chanson du film de
disney était à plaisir pour un showcase
qui a attiré petits et grands samedi un
fait divers pour débuter cette
information qui concerne trappe une
interpellation vient d'avoir lieu dans
le cadre d'un trafic de stupéfiants deux
personnes ont été arrêtées ce lundi
matin dans un premier temps la presse
avait annoncé qu'il s'agissait de
potentiel complice de sid ahmed glam
principal suspect de la tentative
d'attentât contre les églises de
villejuif en avril dernier depuis tout
lien entre ces deux affaires semblent
écarter aujourd'hui j'ai 8 juin c'était
la journée nationale de commémoration
pour de la guerre d'indochine pour
l'occasion une cérémonie s'est déroulée
à versailles devant le monument aux
morts en présence d'élus et d'anciens
combattants l'événement présidé par le
sous-préfet dominique lepidi s'est
ensuite terminée en préfecture avec une
remise de médaille sur la france entière
l'indochine représenter a représenté
malheureusement plus de 300000 morts
donc c'est aussi c'est une guerre qu'on
oublie souvent parce que c'est une
guerre et c'est le lieu et c'est
l'objectif donc aujourd'hui comme tous
les ans de rappeler à nos concitoyens ce
qu'ils ont mais ceux qui sont morts pour
leur liberté
c'est très important parce que c'était
c'est un gameplay dire si la chine fait
rien moi j'ai passé des séjours heinz
chine il ya beaucoup de rizières
moustic paludisme des sentry vous savez
c'était la guerre très dur très dur
surtout là aussi dien bien phu remise de
médailles
oui c'est qu'est ce que ça vous fait ça
vous touche ben ça me touche bien au
coeur parce que je les ai je crois que
là les a gagnées commémoration qui se
déroulait donc ce matin propos
recueillis par william elle la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines a confirmé lors du
dernier conseil communautaire la
fermeture de la maison de
l'environnement situé à magny les
hameaux après la maison de la poésie à
guyancourt c'est une autre structure qui
est touché a directement par les coupes
budgétaires à un collectif de soutien
est en train de se constituer en appel
la pétition a été lancée vendredi soir
comme nous l'expliquent catherine de
l'atome la monture de cette maison et
environnement dont le personnel qui sera
lui aussi mené au réseau des
médiathèques alain le vote l'ancien
maire de magny les hameaux fer de lance
du collectif de soutien à la maison
l'environnement en ce 5 juin dix ans
jour pour jour après l'inauguration du
site
plusieurs habitants se sont rassemblés
pour protester contre cette fermeture
annoncée par la communauté
d'agglomération en raison de la baisse
des dotations et des économies à faire
il ya des choix à faire on peut toujours
faire des choix et dans les périodes de
crise je pense que le mieux c'est quand
même de mettre l'argent là où c'est le
plus utile c'est-à-dire la culture et
l'éducation la santé la vie éducative
l'environnement qui est important
aujourd'hui est le sport de masse la
perte de dotation
cette année de l'état pour la casse qui
c'est l'équivalent en gros du loyer du
vélodrome
pourquoi ce serait seulement les
citoyens qui ferait des efforts on peut
peut-être demander de renégocier le
contrat de ppp avec bouygues pour voir
si on peut pas arrangé les choses
depuis une semaine une pétition circule
elle a recueilli plus de 650 signatures
c'est un endroit qui est hyper
symbolique pour 3 au changement et
voilà qui est un lieu mois enfin qui
voit qu'il ya beaucoup de sens dans
notre vie au quotidien et dans notre
engagement
j'ai déjà utilisé cette maison dans le
cadre d'une formation professionnelle
puisque je suis enseignant et la
communauté d'agglomération elle a pour
mission aussi de répartir l'activité sur
le territoire et il faut savoir que la
ville de magny les hameaux
malheureusement est un petit peu
excentré et si on y implante pas de
lieux comme ça qui peuvent attirer des
événements on risque d'en faire une
ville dortoir la majorité à la casse qui
explique que les missions environnement
seront redéployés au sein du réseau des
médiathèques cela ne convainc pas le
réseau des médiathèques adea peut avoir
des démissions multiples mais s'agissant
de la science et de l'environnement je
vous dis pour organiser des événements
comme des formations comme des
amphithéâtres des projections etc
c'est pas le même équipement c'est pas
la même capacité d'accueil s'est passé
pas le même public
anna le vote espère maintenant
constituer un collectif plus large en
incluant les usagers de la maison de la
poésie à guyancourt dont la fermeture a
également été actée après de longs mois
de préparation nous en avons d'ailleurs
parlé sur cette antenne le festival
alternatiba l'étape saint-quentinoise a
eu lieu ce week-end deux jours de
rencontres de festivités des changes
pour réfléchir à la question du
changement climatique mais aussi à
l'injustice sociale mélanie poker
bienvenue dans le village éphémère
d'alternatiba saint quentin en yvelines
12 quartiers et autant de thèmes pour se
questionner s'informer et proposer
d'alternative à saint quentin en
yvelines
ça a été près de 500 personnes qui ont
participé depuis un an et demi à toutes
les étapes de l'organisation que ce soit
pour pour communiquer pour faire des
actions de sensibilisation pour pour
récolter des fonds parce que c'est un
festival autofinancé
si le réchauffement climatique était au
coeur des préoccupations la réflexion
était aussi à l'injustice sociale à la
culture et à la place du citoyen nous
avons souhaité au sein du festival
alternatiba avoir un quartier démocratie
pour que les citoyens reprennent un peu
la main avec tous ces termes de
démocratie de citoyenneté de faire
entendre leur voix autrement que par
l'insertion d'un bulletin de vote dans
une urne
de temps en temps assez rarement et
et donc faire entendre leur voix par
l'écriture par le dialogue sur le thème
donc de de la démocratie chaque année
nous produisons chaque 1 590 kg de
déchets un chiffre qui a presque doublé
en 40 ans alternatiba c'est donc aussi
l'occasion de sensibiliser pour amener
un changement de comportement nous ce
qu'on cherche à faire s'est émerveillé
pour éveiller c'est à dire en changeant
le regard que les gens vont porter sur
le déchet on cherche à induire des
comportements éco responsables c'est à
dire mettre en place du tri sélectif
faire attention à ce qu'on jette à ce
qu'on consomme et montrer que l'on peut
créer des choses belles à partir de
déchets qui est traditionnellement en
jette on trouve là et c'est le temps
d'un week-end le premier festival
alternatiba d'île de france a accueilli
5000 visiteurs sur ces deux jours de la
verrière nous partons pour versailles ou
dimanche
un avion a dû se poser en catastrophe
dans le domaine du château un avion de
tourisme dont les deux occupants ont été
légèrement blessés il venait de décoller
de l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école
avant de connaître une panne moteur
toujours à versailles premier week-end
d'exposition pour les oeuvres d'anish
kapoor l'artiste originaire de bombay a
pris possession des jardins du château
non sans suite sans susciter certaines
contestations
nous étions présents lors de
l'inauguration en fin de semaine
dernière des images signées patrick
jacques de dixmude
on a l'habitude de voir des expositions
d'art moderne mais là ça atteint le
sommet de l'incompréhensible et du
jamais mort oui ça me choque vraiment ça
me choque pas parce que ça montre je
dirais le mariage du contemporain avec
le
l'antiquité qu'est ce que je peux dire
elle divise les oeuvres d'anish kapoor
présentée au château de versailles du
dirty corner surnommé par ses
détracteurs le vagin de la reine à
shooting into the corner disposées dans
la salle du jeu de paume face à la
fresque de david habitué aux polémiques
après les passages de koons ou de murs à
camille la présidente de l'établissement
public préfère ne pas s'attarder sur le
sujet je comprends qu'il y ait des
polémiques sur l'art contemporain à
versailles à elles ont toujours eu lieu
je crois même qu'elle avait lieu
probablement si on retrouvait les écrits
de l'époque du temps de louis xiv parce
qu'on était d'accord ou pas avec un
artiste je pense que donc c'est normal
que le débat existe sur la présence de
l'art contemporain à versailles mais je
pense que certaines polémiques sont
inutiles voire excessive quant à
l'artiste anish kapoor il assure avoir
uniquement voulu bouleverser les
équilibres dans les jardins de le nôtre
tout en préservant l'intégrité physique
du lieu inutile de rechercher uniquement
des connotations sexuelles présente pour
le lancement de son exposition vendredi
dernier il a précisé ses intentions
je pense que le plus grand problème de
l'art c'est la question du temps quand
vous réalisez quelque chose d'aussi
symétrique le nôtre ici dans les jardins
de versailles vous réaliser quelque
chose de perpétuelles de circulaire
alors quand un artiste vient ici il doit
aussi se demander quelles sont les
autres notion du temps à explorer je
voulais apporter des moments incomplet
principalement avec dirty corner
on ne sait pas si c'est terminé 6es
encore en train d'être réalisé cela
donne une idée de temps peut être pas si
parfait scies circulaires six oeuvres
sont à découvrir à versailles et
notamment ce cube noir traversé par des
noyaux rouge est accessible au public
pour lui donner la sensation d'être à
l'intérieur d'un immense êtres vivants
ou encore ce troublant vortex bassin
circulaire où l'eau s'échappe vers les
profondeurs
on va dans les profondeurs de la terre
on voit ces zones noires qui tournait
ici où toutes les eaux sont uniformes
limpide et cette contradiction entre ce
qui était avant le nôtre et c'est le
propos de l'artiste c'est de montrer ce
qu'il y avait avant ce chef-d'oeuvre
avant ce chef-d'oeuvre avant cette
rigueur avant cette perfection et bien
le monde était sans doute moins beau cas
pour versailles
à découvrir jusqu'au 1er novembre c'est
la huitième fois que le château donne
carte blanche à un artiste contemporain
jamais un chantier si important de
préparation n'avait été menée la reine
des neiges 1 milliard 300 millions de
dollars de recettes à travers le monde
deux oscars et avant qu'un deuxième
épisode ne voit le jour sur grand écran
l'interprète du morceau phare pour la
version française
libéré des livres et d'anaïs delva était
donc à plaisir pour un showcase qui a
forcément attiré un large public florane
parfait et william l
la reine des neiges c'est l analyse
delva est la voix française d'elisa dans
le célèbre dessin animé de disney et
lorsqu'elle donne un showcase pour son
album de nombreux fans répondent
présents et cela à tout âge mais a pas
d'âge pour les disney
vous avez des grands enfants voilà c'est
un rêve non parce que voilà on a
l'habitude de l'entendre de là
de la voir sur internet et là vous
rendrai mal et en plus elle est hyper
jouer je la voyais plus inaccessible sur
deux stars voilà
en fait elle est tout à fait naturel
très sympa et massy à écrire elle est
trop belle mais il faut bien dire la
reine des neiges le plus gros succès du
studio disney et surtout leader des
enfants pas si cool elle a chanté
rebelles
la reine des neiges blanche-neige et
jasmin et de khaled difficile de savoir
qui étaient les plus heureux des enfants
ému de rencontrer la chanteuse ou des
parents ravis de pouvoir immortaliser en
photo ce moment nous avons posé la
question à la principale intéressée
les parents ont toujours envie de
m'adopter parce que je les rends très
calme d'un coup ils sont il ya plus de
bruit et c'est marrant et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas eu la chance d'y être
voici une nouvelle occasion d'en
profiter
je suis doigt le danger
et je reçois à présent libéré des livres
et julie goujon bonsoir mon gardienne de
l'équipe de hand de montigny le
bretonneux équipes féminines c'est votre
hymne en plus et mieux
délivré ce week-end puisqu'il y à cette
montée en nationale une vous avez
remporté ce week end le match de barrage
face à nîmes 30 à 26 à l'extérieur en
plus avant de parler tout de même du
match un mot sur la participation à ces
barrages parce que c'est assez inattendu
au départ vous n'étiez pas qualifié pour
les barrages c'est le havre qui devait
jouer à votre place et finalement ils
n'y sont pas allées on avait 0,5 pour
cent de chance d'y être en fait un
maintenant c'était c'était inespéré
finalement ben on nous a dit que
l'oeuvre pouvait pas y aller
ben c'est un mondial est donc bon alors
ne pouvait pas de toute façon volume en
examen et qu'il chantait 1 et elles ont
le redescendre et donc du coup l'équipe
de l'équipe 2 ne peut pas monter cette
possiblité seynoise et 3e qui
m'entendent qu'on n'a pas fait tout ça
pour rien et donc vous avez pu jouer ce
match de barrage
vous êtes allé sans pression ben ouais
on n'avait rien à perdre de toute façon
il fallait il fallait faire le maximum
on voulait rien regretter donc c'est
vrai que dans le bus c'était plutôt
calme plutôt tranquille puis on a abordé
le match vraiment non mais sans pression
on a commencé c'était très dur
la pression est venue en fait
directement au coup de sifflet du départ
vont santé les filles un peu on était
tout un peu stressé on voulait bien
faire mais on n'y arrivait pas forcément
on a mis le premier buteur à 8 minutes
donc c'est difficile et puis
progressivement l'expérience a fait que
seulement deux buts d'écart deux buts
d'écart à la mi-temps
ouais 4 à l'arrivée c'est à dire que
dans les vestiaires et vous vous êtes
dit quoi vous êtes vis ça va être très
très compliqué aubin honnêtement j'étais
pas dans le vestiaire moi je
m'échauffais mais oui je pense que
c'était samedi au bar faut pas lâcher
c'était une équipe jeune en face donc il
faut il faut rester dedans c'est si nous
on élève notre niveau de jeu il n'y a
pas de raison ça peut passer on n'est
qu'à deux buts
ben il faut tout donner pas mais
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
malgré tout c'est ça ce petit plus
d'expérience que vous restez dans votre
équipe il ya des jeux des joueuses plus
jeunes mais des joueuses expérimentées
un petit mixte en fait il ya beaucoup de
jeunes beaucoup de plus âgés pas dire
vieille
j'oserais pas expérimenter les plus
expérimentés qui ont su calmer le tout
faire en sorte que tout se passe bien
chaque personne a bien joué a joué son
meilleur handball
toutes les filles ont vraiment très bien
joué et ça s'est ressenti à la fin on a
commencé à repasser devant un moment et
je ne pense pas qu'elles sont revenus
peut-être une fois mais après très vite
on a su reprendre l'ascendant et est
délivrée
ensuite il est délivré j'allais dire les
conséquences de la montée maintenant
parce que vous allez jouer en national
une mais est ce que le club est prêt
pour ça aussi
ah bah ça les réunions vont commencer
pour essayer d'envisager justement c'est
d'organiser tout ça je sais pas comment
ils vont faire
c'était prévu en quelque sorte un
c'était l'objectif caché parce qu'ils
avaient monté il ya quelques années par
le passé pour ce club de montigny le
bretonneux la montée qui s'est pas
forcément très bien déroulé parce qu'il
ya une redescente dès l'année suivante
avec une saison très difficile pour pas
dire la catastrophique avec de
nombreuses défaites
là maintenant avec cette expérience là
le club va savoir y faire en tout cas
c'est le sentiment que vous avez j'ai
des chances que les annonces parce que
de toute l'année on en a parlé un moment
dans l'année au milieu de l'année on
était première donc on s'est dit ben
pourquoi pas donc je pense que les
dirigeants ont commencé à regarder un
petit peu essayé d'anticiper le la
fameuse montée on va voir et vous vous
avez envie d'en être
vous allez être les filles sont prêtes
les filles sont toutes prêtes mais bon
malheureusement moi j'ai eu ma mutation
dans le cid a bomb a donc nom vous dit
malheureusement parce que ça va être un
regret bah oui on vit quelque chose
d'exceptionnel c'était c'est un
sentiment tout sportif de vivre moments
comme ça il montait
dans la division au dessus c'est génial
donc oui c'est un peu frustrant pour ma
part de ne pas pouvoir le tester le
jouer avec c'est ce groupe qui avec qui
on s'entend super bien
c'est un groupe qui fonctionne on est on
est soudés on est remis et oui j'aurais
bien aimé le tester vous allez suivre de
toute façon pas c'est sûr j'ai assuré
jean quels souvenirs vous allez garder
de cette saison avec les des bons
souvenirs
les taux longs moments plus difficiles
dans la saison aussi il ya eu un besoin
d'évoquer ce moment vous avez été à la
première place et il ya eu trop de
confiance à un moment un petit peu dans
l'équipe projet s'est passé de la
confiance parce qu'on a on est arrivé à
cette première place parce qu'on s'est
entraînée parce qu'on a joué tout
s'était très bien passée puis d'un coup
c'est vrai que on a commencé à perdre on
a enchaîné défaite forcément une année
ne peut pas être faite peu d'éléments
positifs
c'était dur à quoi des problèmes d'ego
aussi de mésentente
il ya eu quelques mésententes surtout
entre les le staff et nous mais après je
dirais pas que il ya des mésententes
entre nous on s'entend bien et comme je
le dire même avec les jeunes
enfin j'aime considéré comme violent on
arrive à intégrer tout le monde et il ya
une bonne cohésion dans le groupe
donc même avec les coaches finalement il
n'y a pas eu de gros clash
donc après j'ai fait la fête ensemble
international une pour la saison
prochaine vous avez évoqué votre
situation vous allez devoir quitter non
pas parce que vous vouliez l'a quittée
mais parce que c'est une nécessité
la professionnelle au delà de ça les
autres joueuses est ce qu'il y aura
beaucoup de départs est ce que ça a déjà
été évoqué mais je pense que vivre une
saison en nationale 1
va faire faire rester les joueuses
j'espère pour le club après chacun est
libre de faire comme il veut j'espère
pour pour cette équipe qu'elle va rester
comme ça et qu'elle va gagner comme ça
et s'amuser aussi dans ce club
quand on voit les autres équipes qui
évoluent en nationale une montigny a
toute sa place parce qu'il ya vraiment
un fossé entre la n2 est là bas oui un
fossé forcément le niveau est quand même
très élevé je sais pas s'il va y avoir
beaucoup de recrues peut-être il le
faudrait pour pouvoir solidifier un peu
l'équipe avoir à voir j'ai hâte de voir
ce que ça va donner
moi je vais suivre ça mais je sais pas
vous allez continuez vous à jouer au
hand ou pas c'est la question que je
veux vivre ça forcément ça me donne
envie de continuer après on verra
et pourquoi pas retrouver montini par la
suite ouais nationale une voilà dans la
même poule ça serait top
très bien et bien merci beaucoup d'être
passé merci à bateaux faut revenir sur
cette victoire de montigny ce week-end
lors des matches de barrage du match de
barrage et cette victoire 30 à 26 face à
nîmes qui permet donc d'accéder à la
nationale une d'année prochaine
merci à vous tous et félicitations bien
sûr l'ensemble des joueuses que vous
avez représenté toujours en sport
mercredi dernier les enfants des écoles
municipales des longs cours de
coignières de montigny le bretonneux et
de voisins bretons ne se sont affrontés
lors d'ateliers sportifs compétition
organisée au complexe sportif europe à
elancourt à mickaël millero et william l
un parfum de jeux olympiques régné au
complexe sportif europe des longs cours
les enfants de coignières de
montigny-le-bretonneux de
voisins-le-bretonneux et des locaux ont
participé mercredi à la rencontre
interclubs municipal des sports
les ateliers étaient organisés pour
l'occasion cette année nous avons six
ateliers donc là nous sommes dans la
salle d'agrès
on avait on n'a pas recours un parcours
gymniques sur les agrès de gymnastique
nous avons un atelier de jeux d'adressé
et de précision dans la grande salle
dans le dojo nous avons un atelier jeux
d'opposition dans la salle de danse un
atelier danse où il ya une petite
chorégraphie qui est appris aux enfants
et nous avons également deux ateliers à
l'extérieur un atelier hockey et un
atelier athlétisme au total 120 enfants
âgés de 6 à 11 ans ont participé à ces
épreuves tous bien amusés
j'espère j'espère que je reviendrai plus
souvent ici parce que l'occasion de les
voir une fois de plus pour toute l'année
c'est vrai que ce genre de journée c'est
très sympa parce que ça permet de se
rendre compte de ce qu'ils ont fait
toute l'année de les voir profiter parce
que là ils s'éclatent franchement très
intéressant
essayez un peu tous les sports il
rencontre d'autres étals des sports donc
voilà c'est ça en s'amusant c'est une
bonne journée je pense les résultats ne
sont pas pris en compte dans cette
compétition amicale l'objectif est de
faire découvrir de nouveaux sports aux
enfants
on n'a pas du tout un objectif
compétitif le principe de l'école des
sports
d'une manière générale c'est d'être
pluridisciplinaire et non compétitif
c'est ce qui la distingue des clubs donc
l'esprit de compétition est juste là
pour motiver les enfants et créer une
dynamique mais à la fin il ya une
récompense qui sera la même fortement
dans une nouvelle édition inter écoles
municipales devraient être programmées
l'année prochaine les enfants des villes
de plaisir et de maurepas pourrait
rejoindre la compétition dans un instant
le 7-8 sport pour l'ensemble des
résultats du week end rendez vous demain
pour un nouveau journal n'oubliez pas
émissions reportages consultable à la
demande dans notre rubrique replay sur
notre site à mardi donc 18 heures pour
le direct 19h pour la première diffusion